週刊金融日記
2026年7月28日 第七百四十一号
こんな相場だからこそエーアイ半導体株について語ろうか
Alphabetはエーアイせつびとうしを2050億ドルへ増額
しんせんの高級モールの脇から入るモダン中華レストラン
投資対象としての銀について
他
web版
こんにちは。
ふじさわかずきです。
週末は、また、しんせんに行って、買い物して、美味しい中華を食べてきましたわ。
しんせんわんボーダーを出たところには大きなDiDi乗り場がありますね。
ディスプレイが車
がどこに着くかを知らせてくれます。
僕は半分は自分用に『南油服装卸売しじょうの歩き方』を、中国のエーアイのKimiとかLongCatと
かぶん回して作っていたんですが（僕はKimiは話題になる前からちゃんと使っていたわけ
ですよ！
いまは計算資源が足りずに新規申込みが"Waitlist"になっちゃっていますが）、こ
の日は、いろいろバタバタしていて、しんせんに着いたのが夕方の６時半ぐらいで、台風も
来そうだったこともあり、多くのお店が閉店間際だったんで、急いで、知ってるお店に走
って行って、買いたいものをさっさと買っただけでした。
次回は、時間にゆとりを持たせて、エーアイ生成のガイドブックの正確さを確かめてきます！
しんせん・南油服装卸売しじょうの歩き方 2026年（Xサブスク記事）
Xサブスク（月３USD）は、アップルやグーグルにピンハネされるスマホのXアプリか
らではなく、宇宙かいはつを応援するためにも、天才イーロン・マスクさんのXのWebをブラ
ウザで開いていただいて、そこから直接ポチっていただけると助かります。
こんしゅうも読者から興味深い投稿がいくつもあります。
見どころは以下のとおりです。
-メモリ株分析感想・まだ遅くない半導体銘柄
-投資対象としての銀に関してどう思われますか
-エーアイが進化していく中でエムビーエーの価値は下がっていくのでは
-所長は現在「エーアイは世界を変える」とお考えですか
それではこんしゅうもよろしくお願いします。
１．こんな相場だからこそエーアイ半導体株について語ろうか
ここ２週にわたって書いたメモリ半導体の需要編と供給編ですが、最新のエーアイをフル稼働
させなければ到底人間一人では処理しきれないレベルの膨大な報道記事や、複雑な半導体
サプライチェーンの情報を叩き込んで書いたもので、執筆もなかなか大変でしたが、読む
側にとっても、「相当胃もたれする重さ」だったのではないかと思います。
また、タイトルも『メモリ半導体株の低PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか？
』とし
て、最後まで読まないといったいどっちか分からないぞ！
？
みたいなスリリングな、英語
圏の厚い本にありがちな構成にしようと書いていたのですが、僕のXを見たり、メルマガ
のQ&Aコーナーを読むと、もはやネタバレみたいな感じになっているので、もう結論を急
ぐこともないかな、と。
ちなみに、記事に出てきた世界中の計画中・既存のメモリ工場をすべて網羅し、ボト
ムアップでディーラム＋HBM、およびナンドフラッシュの供給とじゅようを精密に予測するモデルをエーアイといっ
しょに作っていました。
これは近々、Xのサブスク等で公開しようと思っていますので、
半導体投資家のみなさんは楽しみにしていてください。
『週刊金融日記 第七百三十九号 メモリ半導体株（Micron、SK hynix、Samsung、Kioxia）の低
PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか 需要編』
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十号 メモリ半導体株（Micron、SK hynix、Samsung、Kioxia）の低
PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか 供給編』
そして、ちょうどタイミングよく、創刊号からの古参読者であり、このエーアイ半導体株の暴
騰の前から、がっつりと株を買いこみ、大きく資産形成できた方から、面白い投稿が届き
ました。
ということで、まずは、読者の方の投稿です。
+++++++++++++++++++++++++++
-メモリ株分析感想・まだ遅くない半導体銘柄
藤沢先生
創刊号からの読者の者です。
40代の会社員で、ミッシェルと名乗らせていただきます。
30代の頃に恋愛工学を学んだおかげで、とても恵まれた女性関係を過ごすことができまし
た。
あらためてお礼申し上げます。
今回久しぶりに筆を執ったのは、さいきんの藤沢先生のメモリ株分析、エーアイ半導体関連のXのサ
ブスクライブ記事が素晴らしいと感じたため、その感想を伝えたかったものです。
長文となってしまいましたが、後半では、今からでも遅くない半導体銘柄についても言及
します。
さて、私は2023年頃から半導体株を買い始め、24年にはエーアイ革命を確信し、エーアイ半導体株に
ほぼ全財産をぶち込むことを決意しました（現預金は数十万程度しか保有せずにあとは
全て投資に回しました）。
結果として、当時2,000万〜3,000万ぐらいだった金融資産（大部分がキャッシュかインデ
ックス）が、この６月末で２億円に到達しました（今はそこから▲30％程度調整していま
すが）。
具体的な銘柄はポジションが大きい順に米株はMicron、TSMC、エヌビディア、ASML、AMA
T、Broadcom、日本株はキオクシアや東京エレクトロン、SBGなどです。
これまでこつこつ積み立ててきたインデックスをどんどん売却しながら、上記の銘柄を買
い進めました。
その過程では当然にして、自分なりに徹底的にリサーチします。
（例えばMicronは23年のIRですでに、「24年のHBMは完売」と記載しています。
私の取得
単価は88ドルなのでテンバガーですね。
自慢ですみません。
）
そんな中で、藤沢先生はエーアイについてずっと、「生成エーアイはスイッチングコストがゼロだか
ら、株価はバブル。
遅かれ早かれいつかは弾けるが、バブルはいつ弾けるか予想できない
もの」というトーンでご自身のビューを展開されていました。
（いまバックナンバーを調べてみたら2026年5月4日時点でも、まだ言っておられました
ね。
）
創刊号からの読者であり藤沢先生のことはとても尊敬しておりますが、エーアイ投資のビューに
ついては正直、「何を言ってるんだ。
はいぱーすけーらーはガンガンCapExを拡大して、
半導体企業は実際にめちゃくちゃ利益出てるぞ。
PERもバブルという水準じゃないし」と
冷ややかに見ておりました。
また、創刊号からの読者としては、「自分でも順張りが苦手だと言ってるし、逆張りが好
きな性格だしな」などとも感じておりました。
それがどうでしょう、キオクシア株爆騰の影響もあったのでしょうか、６月頃から突然ビ
ューを転換され、今やメモリ株について素晴らしい論文を執筆されております。
ご自身でも、メモリ株を投資のトップウェイトにされたとのことでした。
（ちなみに藤沢先生の場合、「トップウェイト」とはご自身の投資資産全体の何％ぐらい
を指すのか、差し支えなければ教えてください。
ちなみに私は、Micronとキオクシアで投
資資産全体の30％ぐらいを占めています。
）
Xのサブスクライブについても、「メルマガで紹介されたレストランはもう全部読んでる
し、エーアイ投資についてはそんなに詳しくないしな」と思ってポチっていませんでしたが（す
みません）、メモリ株需要編・供給編が素晴らしい内容だったのでポチってみたところ、
「エーアイとの徹底対談」は非常に読み応えがあり（特に３つ目のClaudeの指摘は思わず唸りま
した）、その後のTSMC、ASML、Alphabet、Intelの決算のまとめも、その辺の証券会社の
アナリストレポートより、とてもよくまとまっています。
（創刊号からの読者としては、藤沢先生の性格上、どこかで飽きが来たり、サブスクライ
バーの数が増えないとサブスク記事がストップしてしまうのではないかと懸念しているの
で、長期的に継続してほしく感想を書いております。
）
さて、ここまでは感想ですが、ここからは次の投資の話です。
半導体株投資に乗り遅れた方たちも、まだチャンスはあると考えます。
私のエーアイ半導体株の取得価格はかなり低く、スタイルとしては長期投資なので、７月に入っ
てからの株価下落は特に気にしていませんでしたが、藤沢先生の「メモリ株は歴史的なミ
スプライスなのか」の論文を読み、投資意欲が大いに刺激されました。
といっても、キオクシア株は下がったとはいえ、7月25日時点で56,010円です。
ワンショット560万を捻出できる会社員はなかなかいないと思います（私もフルベットし
ているので、他の株をそんなには売れません）。
そんな中、7月10日にSK hynixのADRがNASDAQにじょうじょうしました。
公募価格149ドルに対してロケットスタートだったので指をくわえて眺めていましたが、
その後、株価は落ち着き、7月25日時点で154ドルです。
SK hynixの決算は7月29日に発表されます。
６月に発表されたMicronの決算を見れば、相当に強い決算になることは容易に想像できま
（決算が強くても、直後に株価が上がるかどうかはまた別問題ですが。
）
また、7月29日・30日はマイクロソフト、メタ、アマゾンの決算も続々と発表されます。
CapEx増加の発表があるか楽しみです。
Alphabetは増加しましたね。
また、7月24日付けロイター記事＊によると、SKHynixの崔会長が離婚問題により前妻
へ＄640ミリオンを支払わなければならなくなり、それも同社の株価下落の要因の１つに
なったようです。
幸いなことに前妻の権利は、SKグループのマネジメントコントロールまでには及ばない
とされています。
離婚問題には一家言ある我々にとってはなんとも微笑ましい、絶好の仕込みどきと言える
のではないでしょうか。
昨今の円安ではありますが１株154ドルなら、２万５千円から買えます（長期投資家目
線では、為替リスクはキャピタルゲインで報われると位置づけます）。
私は投資銘柄を一部スイッチングして、取得単価155ドル前後でそこそこ仕込みました
2028年にはどうなっているか、今から楽しみです。
（言うまでもないですが、投資はあくまで自己責任でお願いします！
）
さいごに、26年1月のダボス会議での、革ジャンことジェンスン・ファン氏のこの言葉で、
本投稿を締めたいと思います。
「 エーアイ企業は我々の投資を必要としている。
必要な投資きぼは巨大化しており、この素晴ら
しい投資機会に誰もが参加すべきだ」
ミッシェル
[EN]＊South Korean court orders SK Chairman Chey to pay record $640 mln in divorce[/EN]
+++++++++++++++++++++++++++
2023年からMicron株にフルベットとは、素晴らしいですね。
そして、エーアイ半導体のど真ん
中の銘柄選択も素晴らしいですね！
まったく恐れ入りますわ。
僕はChatGPTが出てきて、最初期のころから界隈の分かっている人たちの発言をフォロ
ーしていて、エーアイにエキサイトしていたんです。
それで、エーアイバブル、いや、バブルではな
く、この壮大なエーアイ相場の初期にはちゃんと乗れていたんですが、その後に、なんかその辺
のインフルエンサーもエーアイ、エーアイ、と言い出して、さらに、香港でウエイクサーフィンのボ
ートの兄ちゃんが、急に証券会社の口座を開いてエヌビディア株買ったというもんだから、あ
あ、これはアカンな、と思って、エーアイをディスるポジションを取ったわけですね。
サーフィンの兄ちゃんがエヌビディア株買ってました。
2024年6月ですが、このときの株価
はだいたい130ドルですね。
あと、個人的にも、エーアイはパターン認識なんで、そんなに緻密なロジックとか無理だろ
う、みたいにも思っていたし、当時のエーアイの性能は、僕の仮説を裏付けるのに十分バカでし
たね。
また、サム・アルトマンとかが言うCapExの規模も、金融のことがよく分かっているか
らこそ、そんなこと起こるわけねぇだろ、と。
彼らがいうCapExが本当に実現したら、こういう規模になるんですが…、とバカにして
いたきぼのCapEx、いや、それ以上が現実に起きました！
とはいえ、エヌビディアの上昇速度も緩やかになっていたし、同期間に、僕が推していた金
とビットコインと東京のたわまんも上がっていたんで、まあ、良かったわけです。
まあ、
僕はエーアイバブルはじけるんじゃないか、と思ったタイミングで、ちょろちょろNASDAQの
Putオプション買ったりしてたんで（買いっぱなしで触らない口座に世界株インデックス
もあるし中国・香港株もあるしで全体はロングなんで、少なくともヘッジしないとな…
と）、いま思うといらんことしてたなぁ、と。
それで、ことしの始め頃から、メモリ半導体がすごいことになっている、というのはこの
辺の半導体のサプライチェーンが本当に分かっている人たちの間では騒ぎになっていまし
た。
とはいえ、この時点では、まだまだ、僕はエーアイの可能性を世間の人たちは過大評価して
いる、と思っていたんで、スルーしていたわけですわ。
そしたら、ヘッジファンドの目ざ
とい人たちや、半導体サプライチェーンを自分で研究できるぐらいの個人投資家の人たち
が、このメモリ半導体株に飛び乗っていて、すごい稼いでいました。
それを見て、投資イ
ンフルエンサー的な人たちの一部もそれに乗っていました。
メモリ半導体株は、すでに率で見たらだいぶ株価が上がっていたんですけど、金もビッ
トコインもパフォーマンス悪くなってきたし、恥を忍んで、僕は遅ればせながらメモリ
半導体株に飛び乗ったんですよ。
まあ、キオクシアの株価が５万円台だった頃ですね。
それで、半導体シリーズさいしょのメルマガを書いたわけです。
『週刊金融日記 第七百三十二号 エーアイバブルでディーラムとエスエスディーが高騰する中でWindowsPCを買ったの
で環境構築とメモリ業界の話』
この時点で、とにかくツルハシ側にすごい金が流れ込んでくる、ということは確信して
いたんですけど、まだ、エーアイそのものには懐疑的で、はいぱーすけーらーの利益のかなりの
部分が循環取引的なもので、怪しいだろう、と思っていました。
エーアイに懐疑的だが、エーアイツル
ハシ側はすごいことになる、というひねくれたビューで、なんならはいぱーすけーらーを
ショートして、エーアイツルハシをロングするポジションがいいかな、とまで検討していまし
た。
これはやらなかったんですが、まあ、今となっては、やっておけばよかったかもしれ
ません（笑）。
それで、はいぱーすけーらー側が、どんなビジネスで、どれぐらい儲かっているのか、
ちゃんと分かってないとダメだなぁ、と思って、自分で手を動かして計算したら、ハイパ
ースケーラーもめちゃくちゃ儲かってるじゃん！
と分かったわけです。
『週刊金融日記 第七百三十八号 エーアイ企業はトークン製造工場を建設してトークンを世界に売る簡単
なビジネスです』
遅ればせながら、このビッグウェーブには乗っていくしかないなあ、と。
それで、まあ、僕が買ったメモリ株は、僕が半導体シリーズを執筆している期間に、ち
ょうど良いタイミングで上昇が加速していき、あっという間にキオクシア株もディーラムの
イーティーエフも２倍以上になっていき、テンション上がりましたわ。
恥を忍んで、買ってよかっ
た、と。
そして、我ながら、すごいな、と。
で、いま、キオクシア株もディーラムも僕が始めた頃の株価に戻ってきたわけですね（笑
）。
（編集注）
ついついキオクシアの歌まで作って調子に乗ってましたわ……。
メモリ株の株価は２倍になった後に、半分になって戻ってきたわけですが、めげずに
KOSPIも買ってポジション増やしましたわ……。
それで、なんで株価が下がったのかというと、韓国のレバレッジだとか、中国のCXMT
やYMTCの台頭とか、理由はいろいろあるし、それらは漠然とした投資家たちのセンチ
メントの悪化で、分かっている人たちからすると、メモリを始めエーアイ半導体株のファンダメ
ンタルズはむしろ良くなっているわけです。
とはいっても、株価は雰囲気で動きます。
メモリ株のかぶかしゅうえきりつは10倍が正しいのか、５倍が正しいのか、３倍が正しいのかは、雰囲気
で決まります。
それで、今、いちばん投資家が心配していることって、ツルハシ側はハイパースケーラ
ーの年間１兆ドル以上のCapExが売上になっているんだから、決算で爆益が出続けるのは
当たり前で、そこじゃないんですよね。
１兆ドル使っているはいぱーすけーらーは将来的
にちゃんとエーアイで儲かるんか、ということなんですよ。
そこが儲からなかったら、ツルハシ
側も先細りになって、さいきんの爆益は、単に一時的なものだった、というエーアイ懐疑論者やシリ
コンサイクル論者たちの言う通りになるわけです。
そこで、僕たちみたいな、ちゃんとトークンの製造原価と販売価格まで把握している人
たちからすると、はいぱーすけーらーも儲かっているんだ！
と、みんなに教えてあげて、
みんなの不安を取り除きたいわけですよ。
センチメントの悪化を止めたい。
でも、問題なのは、僕たちのようなエーアイ半導体の未来を信じている人たちって、ミッシェ
ルさんもそうなんだけど、メモリ半導体株に代表されるツルハシ銘柄たくさん買ってるの
に、はいぱーすけーらー買ってないじゃん、ということなんですよ。
問題は。
他人の金ではいぱーすけーらーを支えたいんですね。
僕ははいぱーすけーらーは儲かっ
ているというのは嘘偽りがない、僕が自分で確かめたことなんですが、だからって、限り
ある資金を、ツルハシ側じゃなくて、はいぱーすけーらーの方に賭けないんですよね。
これが何が問題かというと、ここがまさにエーアイバブルのアキレス腱なわけです。
まだ、はいぱーすけーらーのフリーキャッシュフローがちょっとマイナスになるぐらい
で回っているんですが、2027年にガイダンス通りにCapExを増やすには、増資や社債で資
金を調達していかないといけないわけです。
投資家がはいぱーすけーらーのCapExに不安
をいだいていたら、社債の金利が上がっちゃうんですよね……。
で、僕たちエーアイ半導体投資
家は、そこは他人の金でしっかりと支えてもらいたいわけですよ。
まあ、この辺の本音というか、言動とやってることの不一致があるから、僕たちが、い
かにはいぱーすけーらーが儲かっているか、いかにエーアイデータセンター投資が素晴らしいこ
となのか、とXで日々滔々と語っていても、あんまりしじょうには響かないんだと思うんです
まあ、しじょうのセンチメントがどう動くかは別として、僕としては、今回ミッシェルさん
をはじめとする読者のみなさんとこうしてエーアイや半導体について語り合ったことや、Xのサ
ブスクで公開しているエーアイとの対談記事、足元で作成したメモリ需給モデルの記録を、しっ
かりとこの『週刊金融日記』のメルマガやXなどに残しておきたいんですよね。
このエーアイ相場がこのまま突き抜けるのか、あるいはどこかで大きな壁にぶつかるのか、本
当のところは誰にも分かりません。
だからこそ、今こうして僕たちが考え、ポジションを取り、熱く語った記録を、データ
センターのエスエスディー上の記録としてしっかりと刻んでおいて、数年後、2029年あたりに読み返
して、みんなで答え合わせをしたいわけです。
「あの時、僕たちの言った通り爆益だったな！
」と高笑いしているのか、それとも「い
やー、やっぱりエーアイバブルは弾けましたね……」と苦笑いしながら過去のメルマガを
読み返しているのか（笑）。
どんな結末になるにせよ、数年後の答え合わせを楽しみにしつつ、この歴史的なビッグ
ウェーブを読者のみなさんと一緒にリアルタイムで観察し、しっかり楽しんでいきましょ
（言うまでもなく、投資はあくまで自己責任でお願いします！
）
編集注：月曜日にも火曜日にも下がったんで、だいぶふくみそんになりました（笑）。
追記：
こんしゅうは、マイクロソフト、メタ、アマゾンなど、重要な決算があるんで、エーアイアナリストをぶん回
しますわ。
そして、ディーラム・HBM・ナンドフラッシュの全工場をカバーしたボトムアップの供給・需要モデル
も、なんとかこんや中に出します。
もう、ほぼ出来ています！
Xサブスク（月３USD）は、アップルやグーグルにピンハネされるスマホのXアプリからでは
なく、宇宙かいはつを応援するためにも、天才イーロン・マスクさんのXのWebをブラウザで
開いていただいて、そこから直接ポチっていただけると助かります。
ネタバレですが、これがいま思っていることですね。
こっちも。
２．こんしゅうのマーケット
2026年7月17日-2026年7月24日の週間パフォーマンス
[EN]TOPIX:      4011.31, +2.3% (1w), +17.1% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Nikkei225: 64611.15, +0.7% (1w), +28.4% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]S&P500:     7411.98, -0.6% (1w),  +8.3% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]USD/JPY:     163.79, +0.9% (1w),  +4.7% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]EUR/JPY:     186.24, +0.3% (1w),  +1.4% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Oil(WTI Fut): 89.31, +8.3% (1w), +55.5% (YTD)[/EN]
Alphabetはエーアイせつびとうしを2050億ドルへ増額、やや値を戻したメモリ株と売られたハイ
パースケーラー、Kimiが揺さぶる米国エーアイ覇権（金融日記 Weekly 2026/7/17-2026/7/2
せんしゅう（7月17日−24日）のかぶしきしじょうは、前週の半導体株暴落からの自律反発と、エーアイ投資
の採算性を巡る売りが交錯した。
週間ではTOPIXが2.3％、日経平均が0.7％上昇した一
方、S&P500は0.6％安だった。
日本では三菱商事（+10.6％）、三菱UFJ（+8.1％）、東
京海上（+7.8％）など大型バリュー株が買われ、TOPIXが日経平均を大きく上回った。
ド
ル円は163円台へ円安が進み、WTI原油先物は8.3％上昇した。
そして、注目のエーアイ関連だが、Micronは8.5％、キオクシアは7.5％上昇したいっぽうで、
[EN]Alphabetは7.8％、Metaは7.9％、Amazonは6.1％、Oracleは9.0％下落した。
[/EN]
Alphabetの決算は、事業面では非常に強かった。
売上高は前年同期比24％増の1198億
ドル、グーグル Cloudは82％増の248億ドルとなり、Cloudの営業利益率は35.6％まで上昇
した。
さらに2026年のせつびとうし計画を従来の1800億−1900億ドルから1950億−2050億ド
ルへ引き上げた。
エーアイじゅようが弱いから投資を減らすのではなく、需要にきょうきゅうが追いつかない
ため、さらに増額したのである。
そして、その結果、Q2のせつびとうし449億ドルが営業キャ
ッシュフローを上回り、フリーキャッシュフローは赤字となった。
Cloudの高成長によっ
てエーアイじゅようの実在は証明されたが、かぶしきしじょうが次に求めているのは、この巨額投資が資本コ
ストを上回るリターンを生むという証明である。
そのためAlphabet株は売られたが、設備
投資の恩恵を受けるMicronやキオクシアには買い戻しが入った。
Intelの決算も強かった。
売上高は25％増の161億ドル、調整後EPSは0.42ドルで、デー
タセンター・エーアイ部門は59％増収となった。
Q3ガイダンスも市場予想を大きく上回り、
2026年のせつびとうしを200億ドル超へ増額した。
先のASML、TSMC、今回のAlphabet、
Intelまで、各社が揃って示しているのは、エーアイ半導体の注文不足ではなく、需要に応えるた
めの工場、装置、メモリ、電力が足りないという現実である。
いっぽう、中国Moonshot エーアイのKimiが米国最先端モデルに迫る性能を示し、オープンウエイ
トでの公開も予定されていることは、米国エーアイ企業の将来収益に不安を抱かせた。
十分な
ジーピーユーとメモリを持つ企業なら、米国企業のエーピーアイへ料金を払い続けず、自社環境で高性能
モデルを運用できるからだ。
米国では中国製オープンモデルを規制しようとする動きもあ
るが、週末にはエヌビディアのジェンスン・フアンシーイーオーがXで、オープンモデルへの包括的な
規制に反対する立場を示した。
また、中国エーアイの勃興はモデル層だけにとどまらない。
中国最大のメモリ半導体メーカー
であるCXMT（長?メモリ）は27日に上海証券取引所の科創板へじょうじょうする。
アイピーオーによる調
達額は579億2000万元（約86億ドル）と、ことしのアジア最大きぼで、追加売り出しがすべ
て実施されれば666億1000万元に達する可能性がある。
調達資金はディーラムの生産能力増強
や研究開発などに使われる。
これは世界的なエーアイせつびとうしとメモリじゅようの強さを裏付ける一
方、長期的にはMicron、SKハイニックス、Samsung電子など既存大手に対する中国勢の
競争圧力が強まることも意味する。
筆者が週刊金融日記第七百三十八号で書いたように、はいぱーすけーらーは巨大なエーアイデータセ
ンターを建設し、トークンしょりを世界へ販売するビジネスである。
グーグル Cloudの82％成
長と高い利益率は、この事業にも十分な収益性があることを示した。
中国モデルとの競争
激化は価格を下げる可能性があるが、同時に世界で生成されるトークン量を増やし、計算
資源へのじゅようをさらに押し上げる。
したがって筆者は、エーアイデータセンターへのせつびとうしは
こんごも加速し、エーアイ半導体株、とりわけメモリ半導体企業に対して強気の見方を維持してい
中東では米軍機の増派からイランへの大規模攻撃が懸念され、原油価格がさらに上昇し
たが、週末にはトランプ大統領らが戦争激化への懸念を示し、攻撃はいったん保留された
と報じられた。
またしてもTACOが期待されているが、正式な停戦ではなく、原油のリス
クプレミアムが簡単に消える状況では、まだないだろう。
こんしゅうはマイクロソフト、メタ、アマゾン、アップルの決算が相次ぐ。
注目点は、各社がAlphabet
と同様にエーアイせつびとうしを増額するか、そしてCloudとエーアイ事業の利益が投資負担に見合って
いるかである。
せつびとうし増額と収益化の両方が確認されれば、直近のメモリ半導体株の急
落は絶好の押し目だったことになる。
Xサブスクで、Alphabet、Intelのエーアイによる決算分析や、エーアイバブルの現在位置について筆者
とエーアイの対談記事が読めます。
購読希望の方は、アップルにピンハネされるiPhoneアプリか
らではなく、ぜひスマホやPCのブラウザからXのサイトを開き、そこで直接サブスクリ
プションを登録して、イーロン・マスク氏の宇宙開発も同時に応援してください。
Alphabet 2026年Q2決算 Cloud 82パーセント成長が示した「エーアイデータセンターじゅようの実在」と、
通期CapEx最大2,050億ドルへの再増額が突きつけた「投資回収」の問い（Xサブスク）
2026年Q2決算 米ファウンドリ復権と18A量産の現在地：15年ぶりの高成長は本物か
（Xサブスク）
中国エーアイ・Kimiの衝撃、米専門家「アンソロピック最新型と僅差」
[EN]●What is China’s Kimi K3 and why is the US so rattled by it?[/EN]
中国メモリ大手CXMT、27日上海上場　アジアでことし最大のアイピーオー
週刊金融日記 第七百三十七号 Micronと立場が逆転したアップルが泣きつく中国のディーラム企業
CXMT（長?メモリ）について解説します、他
週刊金融日記 第七百三十八号 エーアイ企業はトークン製造工場を建設してトークンを世界に売る簡単
なビジネスです、他
ジェンセン・フアンのさいしょのポストが、オープンモデルへの規制に反対するものだっ
[EN]●American refueling tankers to be stationed in IDF bases, Ramon Airport as US[/EN]
[EN]reinforces Middle East[/EN]
米副大統領ら、イランとの戦争激化に懸念示す　攻撃は「保留」と国防総省関係者
7月27日(月)
6月企業サービス価格指数
米6月耐久財受注
米2年国債入札
米5年国債入札
独7月Ifo景況感指数
決算：キヤノン、他
7月28日(火)
米FOMC（-7/29）
米5月ケース・シラー住宅価格指数
米5月住宅価格指数
米7月リッチモンド連銀製造業指数
米7月しょうひ者信頼感指数
米7年国債入札
決算：キーエンス、スクリン、日東電、他
7月29日(水)
ウォーシュ米連邦準備理事会（エフアールビー）議長会見
決算：日立、アドバンテ、コマツ、野村、マイクロソフト、メタ、他
7月30日(木)
日銀 金融政策決定会合（-7/31）
日7月消費動向調査
日2年国債入札
米4-6月期ジーディーピー速報値
米6月個人所得
米6月個人消費支出（PCE）
決算：東エレク、みずほ、JT、パナソニック、武田、富士通、京セラ、アップル、Amazo
n、他
7月31日(金)
中国7月製造業購買担当者景気指数（PMI）
決算：キオクシア、三井住友、ソニーＧ、村田製、三菱電、HOYA、住友商、ルネサス、
住友電、ファナック、TDK、デンソー、第一三共、JR東日本、JR東海、SBI、
[EN]ExxonMobil、Chevron、他[/EN]
8月1日(土)
8月2日(日)
３．ブログではいえないお店
-しんせんの高級モールの脇から入るモダン中華レストラン
冒頭で書きましたが、しんせんに行ってきました。
ここのレストランに行くのは３回目ぐ
らいです。
僕たちの南油服装卸売市場からそれほど遠くなく、また、僕がしんせんに行くときにいち
ばんよく使うしんせんわんボーダーからもそれほど遠くないところに、深?湾万象城（
Shenzhen Bay MixC）という高級ショッピングモールがあります。
エルメスやシャネル、
ルイヴィトンなどのラグジュアリーブランドが集結していて、まあ、僕は全く購買意欲が
起きません。
まあ、六本木ヒルズのESTNATIONとかGINZA SIXみたいなやつで
す。
きぼはそれよりはるかに大きいけど。
10万円のTシャツとかジーンズとか、いったい
誰が買うんか、と。
いつもフェラーリとかたくさん止まっていますが……。
僕は南油バー
ジョンで満足ですわ（笑）。
深?湾万象城。
さすがに、これぐらいになると中国ではポンコツすぎて使い物にならな
いグーグル Mapでもそれなりにちゃんと写真とか揃ってますな。
しかし、このモールの中じゃなくて、なぜかこのモールの横から入っていくレストラン
があります。
高級感があって、オシャレなモダンチャイニーズなんだけど、大箱なので、
予約せずともだいたい入れて、そして、美味しいですね。
元古雲境（ユエングーユンジン、yu?n g? y?n j?ng）というお店です。
元古雲境（深?湾万象城店）
深?市南山区粤海街道科苑南路2888号深?湾万象城西?（外?一楼）
+86-150-5131-0269
１人当たり予算：300元（約7000円）ぐらい
以下、大?点?（DianPing、中国の食べログ）を運営している美団が作ったLongCatと
いうエーアイに教えてもらった情報です。
やはり、何気に、このマイナーエーアイがこういうのはいち
ばん得意っぽいです。
まあ、中国では５番手か６番手ぐらいのエーアイなんですけど、いろいろ
な知能テスト的なものでは、グーグルのエーアイぐらいには勝ってるっぽいですね。
ここは二十四節気（中国の戦国時代の頃に発明された、四季・気候の視点で一年を区分
する方法）をコンセプトにした、北京の路地裏からスタートしたモダンチャイニーズで
す。
しんせんのこの一等地にもオープンしました。
前述のように、お店の入り口はモールの外周にあって少し分かりにくく、隠れ家感があ
ります。
中に入ると、木を基調とした禅をテーマにした落ち着いた空間が広がっていま
す。
スタッフはイケメンが多いです。
料理は季節ごとにメニューが更新され、野山椒の酸味と辛味を効かせた牛肉の煮込み
「白酸湯野山椒文火牛」や、ジャスミンの香りがする鶏スープ、そして看板デザートの
「柚子酪（柚子とチーズのスイーツ）」など、見た目も味も非常に洗練されています。
中国酒や詩的な名前のカクテルも豊富です。
中国メインランドでは高級店なんでしょうが、物価の安い中国ですから、まあ、１人
5000円〜8000円ぐらいですね。
香港から安いイタリアンワインを持ち込みました。
ビールは安い青島は置いてなくて、オシャレな地ビールになります。
まあ、美味しいで
とにかく全てが美味しいです。
ということで、しんせん旅行で、オシャレ中華に行きたかったら、オススメです。
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.1
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.2
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.3
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.4
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.5
しんせん・南油服装卸売しじょうの歩き方 2026年
４．ふじさわかずきの身もフタもない人生相談
-投資対象としての銀に関してどう思われますか
藤沢先生、いつも本質的な学びをありがとうございます。
さいきんの金融しじょうは大半が、メモリ、半導体に資金が集まっているかと思いますが、今回は
「こんごの銀（シルバー）への投資の可能性」について、先生のマクロな視点からのご見解
を伺いたく、質問させていただきます。
現在、以下の４つの理由から、投資対象としての銀のポテンシャルに非常に注目していま
・実需と装飾の二面性：金（ゴールド）とは異なり、銀は宝飾品としての価値だけでな
く、工業用素材としての強烈な実需を兼ね備えている点。
・金銀比価の乖離：金価格が高値圏で推移するいっぽうで、金銀比価は約100倍と歴史的に見
ても大きな乖離があり、銀に割安感があるのではないかという点。
・価格の底堅さ：さいきんの銀価格が比較的落ち着いた動きを見せており、リスクリワードの
観点から仕込み時として優位性があるのではないかと考えている点。
・こんごの爆発的な電力需要：エーアイ普及などを背景とした世界的な電力・エネルギーじゅようの増
加において、導電性に最も優れた銀は「絶対に譲れない価値（不可欠な素材）」になるは
ずだという点。
さくねん末の貴金属バブルからようやく価格帯も落ち着きを取り戻してきたような雰囲気であ
り、そろそろ買い時なのではないかと考えています。
できれば40ドル付近まで落ちてほしいところですが流石に難しいのではないかと思ってい
ます。
こんごの投資対象としての銀の可能性を、先生はどのように評価されますでしょうか？
ぜひ、忌憚のないご意見をお聞かせいただけますと幸いです。
よろしくお願いいたしま
-ふじさわかずきの回答
僕は、ゴールドやビットコインには、ポジティブです。
というのも、背後の大きなストーリーは変わりません。
それらは、以下のバックナンバーに書いたことなので、興味のある方はよく読んでくださ
『週刊金融日記 第六百十三号 ビットコインについて宗旨替えしました』
『週刊金融日記 第六百三十七号 銃とビットコインはアメリカ国民にとって自由と財産を守る手段
である』
『週刊金融日記 第六百九十七号 なぜ金はこんなに上がっているのか？
多極化により世界はゆる
やかな金本位制へ』
つまり、ドルなどの法定通貨が「仮に」頼れなくなった場合、価値を保存し続けるにはど
うしたらいいか？
という問に対する答えですね。
そして、その誰も管理者がいないアセットの代表が人類がずっとこの目的で古来より使っ
てきた金であり、それのデジタル版である、非中央集権の暗号資産であるビットコインな
わけです。
その他は、金が高すぎる、あるいは、ビットコインが高すぎるし、これらはすでにアセッ
トとしてメジャーすぎるので、たとえ上がっても、ここから数十倍は期待できないので、
次の金、次のビットコインも買われるという構図です。
銀は、まさにこの点でいうと、Ethereumみたいなものですよね。
金も銀も、工業的価値で、理論的な最低の価格は守られているわけですが、工業的価値だ
けならこんなに高くはなりませんね。
やはり、価値が保存される、そして、その根本は、他の人も価値があると思うから、とい
うどこまで行ってもトートロジーでしか説明できない、この不思議な価値を人類がみなで
信じることができる物語が必要なわけです。
そして、金も銀もビットコインも、さいきんはパフォーマンスは悪いんですが、それは、エーアイ半
導体株などのよりホットな投資対象が出てきてしまって、そっちを買いたい投資家が多く
なったからでしょうね。
まあ、さいきんは、エーアイ半導体株は売られていますが……。
-エーアイが進化していく中でエムビーエーの価値は下がっていくのでは
質問させていただきます。
生成エーアイが進化していく世の中において、エムビーエーやMOT（技術経営）の価値は下がっていくの
ではないでしょうか？
イーロン・マスク氏は「エムビーエー取得者は不要」という趣旨の発言もしていますが、藤沢先生
のご意見を聞かせてください。
テスラシーイーオー、米企業の「エムビーエー化」を批判
-ふじさわかずきの回答
僕はもともとエムビーエーをどちらかというとディスる側ではあったんでバイアスというか偏見が
あるかもしれませんが、学べる中身自体は、僕が外資系証券会社で働いていた10年以上も
前から、1000円の本に書いてある（いまは紙の値段や流通コストが上がり3000円か）、み
たいなことはよく言われておりました。
また、トップ企業でバリバリ稼いで出世している人たちは、エムビーエーのために仕事を２年離れ
る、みたいなことはやらないんで、学生にはトップクラスが抜けているし（もちろんエムビーエー
の後に世界トップ人材になった人は腐るほどいます！
＊）、まあ、欧米でも、ぶっちゃけ
た話、(1) 学部の卒業大学が微妙な人たちを一流の学歴にする、(2) 給料が低い業界で働
いていた人たちが投資銀行やコンサルティング会社のような給与水準の高い会社にエント
リーするため、(3) 給料が高いがすぐクビになる業界で働いていた人がめでたくクビにな
ってパッケージでホクホクしながら２年間羽を伸ばす、的な場所ではあったわけです。
まあ、しかし、僕ぐらいの年齢になって周りを見渡すと、エムビーエー持っている人は、中高年に
なってきた時に、そのまま企業のマネジメント側に行けている確率は高そうなんで、そこ
まで無駄じゃなかったんだな、みたいにも思います。
アメリカの大学は学費のインフレが酷いですし、そもそも外国人が働けるビザを出し渋る
ようになってきたみたいなんで、いまの学費とかいろいろ考えると、そこで学べる知識自
体はエーアイでさらに陳腐化するんで、積極的に金を払いにいくもんでもないかな、とは個人的
には思いますが、もちろんぜんぜん否定するもんじゃないですよ。
だいたい、そもそも外資系証券会社とかヘッジファンドとかで億単位の金を稼いでいた
り、アンソロピックやオープンエーアイで億単位の報酬をもらってエーアイ開発していたり、エヌビディアでジーピーユーの
設計している人たちがエムビーエーなんか行くわけないんですけど、かといって、世の中のサラリ
ーマンの99.9％はそんなことしてないんで、キャリアアップのチャンスだと思って、さら
にいろいろ学費とか滞在費とかがなんとかなってるなら、そして、何より合格したなら、
行けばいいと思いますよ！
社費とか国費留学なら、もちろん、行くしかないですわ！
Good Luck!
世界トップ企業のシーイーオーでは、アップルとマイクロソフトとグーグルとアマゾンのトップがエムビーエー
ですね。
まあ、だから、僕的には、これらの企業はサラリーマン的になってきて、ちょっ
と物足りないんですが。
イーロン・マスクとか、サム・アルトマンとか、なんか別格です
ごいじゃないですか（笑）。
[EN]Apple：Tim Cook（ティム・クック） - Duke University Fuqua School of Business（198[/EN]
[EN]Microsoft：Satya Nadella（サティア・ナデラ） - University of Chicago Booth School of[/EN]
[EN]Business（1997）Weekend MBAプログラム[/EN]
[EN]Alphabet（Google）：Sundar Pichai（サンダー・ピチャイ） - Wharton School, University[/EN]
[EN]of Pennsylvania（2002）[/EN]
[EN]Amazon：Andy Jassy（アンディ・ジャシー） - Harvard Business School（1997）[/EN]
-所長は現在「エーアイは世界を変える」とお考えですか
所長、いつもお世話になっております。
エーアイについて質問させてください。
所長のご発言を追っているのですが、いぜんは「エーアイバブルだ」とか「エーアイは大したことない」
といったお話もあったかと思います。
いっぽうで、さいきんのメールマガジンを拝見すると、「エーアイとの壁打ちが人間を超えた」ともお
っしゃっています。
そこで、所長が今現在、どのように考えていらっしゃるかご意見をお聞かせください。
(1) 現在のエーアイの進捗に対する見立て
(2) エーアイがAGI（汎用人工知能）になり、世界を変えるという見通しについて
テックファーストでありながら、どこか夢物語のような側面もある中で、この人工知能と
いうものが実際にどこまで我々の世界を変えていくのか。
所長のご意見をいただけますと嬉しいです。
-ふじさわかずきの回答
エーアイはすでに、特にホワイトカラーの仕事に入り込んでいますし、そういう意味では、もう
普及はしているんですよね。
それで、メモリもジーピーユーもまだまだぜんぜん足らないから、エーアイの社会インパクトをどう控え
めに見ても、好むと好まざるとにかかわらず、あと、２、３年の世界は、エーアイとそれを支
える半導体で回っていくことは確実なんですわ。
だから、投資でも、また、メルマガ執筆みたいな文筆業でも、これにがっつり取り組まな
いという選択肢はないって感じですね。
まあ、個人的には、博士号を半導体物理学の分野で取ったんで、キャリアで初めて直接的
に知識が生きるものが世界の中心になるわけで、これは面白いなあ、と思っているところ
ですわ。
『週刊金融日記 第五百二十一号 地方出身の平凡な大学生だった私が海外大PhDコースにフルサポ
ート奨学金をもらって留学できた夢をつかむ力』
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。